[Applause]  it's been a long time  sorry that okay  everything's on--okay you are the master  of every situation it's for you  [Music]  taxes but doing two weeks we don't have  any of them what are you talking about  I can't afford it which what don't you  understand you're not going to college  or doing anything meaningful with your  life what if I went film in it it's  repeated in her does she want to make  you feel better  where were you we had a crisis you're  not really the way a guy supposed to be  just said you were gonna call me  why I mean you called me what you're  doing is sacrificing yourself for  someone you know much about guns Harley  I wanna make a call we're not done yet  don't talk to me you're disgusting tell  me the truth you only I didn't leave  anyone on purpose  I know who you are Joe along here but I  can't help you if you won't let me kind  of the truth  is you really compare  so my question to you is why did you  kill  you